notre seat du mercredi avec Jean-Luc
Landry bonsoir et Carlos l'étao qui est
avec nous ce soir exceptionnellement
bonsoir Carlos lettaro merci d'être avec
nous je pose la première question Carlos
d'ailleurs quand Desjardins nous dit ben
on s'en va probablement récession dans
la deuxième moitié mais à jour ces
chiffres ça s'appelle une récession on
est assez pessimiste aussi du côté du
Québec avec une croissance qui est très
très faible est-ce que vous partagez un
peu ce pessimisme de déjà je partage la
perspective des jardins je trouve pas
que ça soit nécessairement très
pessimiste non je pense que c'est
réaliste oui est-ce que ce qui est à
mesure ce que je trouve de nouveau un
peu dans les le scénario de Desjardins
c'est que le ralentissement enfin la
faiblesse économique se poursuit en 2024
donc oui on a ralentissement maintenant
probablement récession en fin d'année
mais 2024 ça sera pas une année si forte
que ça non plus non puis vous trouvez
pas sur pessimiste c'est réaliste c'est
réaliste Jean-Luc du Canada veut
ralentir l'inflation le moyen de le
faire c'est que tout le chômage doit
monter alors qui dit aux autres chômage
ça implique une arrestation donc
vous voyez ça aussi dans votre boule de
cristal cette grille comme scénario déjà
au début quand les taux d'intérêt sont
même monter la Banque du Canada annoncé
aux États-Unis on commence à voir des
signes de faiblesse construction
résidentielle HT les dépenses
d'investissement baisse des
gouvernemental va être aussi suite à la
pandémie il y aurait seulement le
consommateurs et le consommateur a
encore beaucoup d'argent qui vient de la
pandémie et donc c'est ce qui maintient
l'économie encore mais on voit on voit
quand même des ralentissements et donc
est-ce que ça veut dire des hauts une
autre puis là on va parler du Canada une
autre hausse de taux d'intérêt compte
tenu du fait que l'inflation a remonté
un peu d'un dixième de points au cours
du dernier mois ce qui est vu comme une
surprise quand même là une légère
surprise mais bon 4,3 c'est une hausse
très légère les chiffres ne d'un mois à
l'autre maintenant est-ce que pour le
taux d'intérêt de l'étau pendant est-ce
que je pense qu'en jouant il y aura pas
de hausse du tour on va surveiller
surtout la prévision de la Banque du
Canada avec le rapport de la République
monétaire au mois de juillet si la
banque Canada change son son sa
prévision ça ça pourrait envoyer un
signal qui aurait une hausse de tour si
la banque demeure
sa prévision deme relativement en
changer sur le scénario le scénariste
c'est vrai que les taux vont rester
élevés mais longtemps je pense que ce
qui avait un scénario de baisse de taux
à la fin de l'année moi je mettrai ça
sur la glace des jardins là le scénario
de baisse de toit à partir de la fin de
2023 Jimmy Jones nous disait en entrevue
tantôt ça se peut que ça reste aussi
mais officiellement dans ces données on
parle d'une baisse de taux fin 2023 la
Canada est plus sensible au taux
d'intérêt qu'aux États-Unis à cause du
marché hypothécaire aux États-Unis les
spectacles sont financés long terme la
hausse de
affecte pas le consommateur
immédiatement tandis qu'au Canada ou
surtout qu'on renouvelle son hypothèque
et vous savez c'est 5 ans mais ça veut
dire que beaucoup de gens à un an deux
ans trois ans alors il y a à mon avis on
n'a pas besoin de hausser les taux tout
ce qu'on a à faire c'est les garder là
et graduellement des dépenses convention
de consommation vont se mettre à bercer
il y a un risque d'augmenter les taux
aussi de provoquer une chute de
l'économie trop forte qui est pas
nécessaire donc il faut s'arrêter dans
les hausses une très bonne idée je
resterai là et baisser les taux ensuite
plus tard plus tard 2024 vous êtes
Carlos probablement
parce que si vous regardez les salaires
la tendance inflationniste fondamentale
ça baisse plus beaucoup en mode 4 %
la partie 4 à 2 ça va être très long je
pense c'est ça la clé c'est que on a
quand même réussi à baisser l'inflation
de 8 à 4
maintenant passer de 4 à 2 ça va prendre
du temps donc on peut pas se précipiter
dans des baisses de taux d'intérêt faut
maintenir cette pression pour amener
l'inflation vraiment
Olivier Blanchard par exemple qui est
très reconnu mondialement
cessé de regarder deux visites bien trop
cher
à avoir je pense pas que les banques
centrales pourraient le changer comme ça
mais c'est peut-être quelque chose à
regarder de façon un peu plus
structurelle oui parce que deux ou trois
pour cent c'est la grande question et ça
fait une différence
point de vue du taux de chômage puis de
comportement de l'économie d'un prochain
deux ans c'est très intéressant ce que
vous soulevez Jean-Luc on va le ramener
en débat je vais vous amener sur
Christophe Freeland qui a défendu sa
gestion des finances publiques devant un
commis le Comité des finances à la
Chambre des communes exercices qui est
devenu très partisans finalement parce
que les conservateurs ont beaucoup
attaqué madame Freeland madame on a
répondu aussi par la bouche de ces
canons je dirais aux conservateurs aussi
là dessus et c'est Joël Denis Bellavance
dans la presse qui dit ce matin dépense
un contrôlée déficit à répétition au
substantiel des frais d'intérêt sur la
dette manque de rigueur budgétaire si
tant que les conservateurs reprochent au
gouvernement Trudeau est-ce que c'est le
cas oui on a déjà parlé lors de la revue
du budget là
c'est pas un budget crédible il y a pas
de contrôle de dépenses suffisant pour
arriver même aux prévisions que Madame
fullano présenté selon moi
maintenant il y a quand même faudrait
mettre un petit bémol pour une chose là
si on fait des gros déficites pour des
infrastructures pour moderniser notre
économie l'adapter aux nouvelles
environnement
on peut le tolérer
un peu différente moi je pense pas que
que les budgets soient si irresponsable
que ça les déficits sont quand même
relativement modestes et pour les
prochaines années on voit que déficit
diminue ce qui fait monter beaucoup le
déficit projeté c'est deux choses
d'abord les politiques sociales qui sont
comme influencés par la pression du NPD
le système
d'assurance dentaire par exemple ça ça
coûte très cher mais politiquement je
pense que le gouvernement a choisi qui
n'avait pas le choix que de le faire et
l'autre côté sont les dépenses
infrastructures les 80 milliards sur sur
quelques années pour la
transgénergétique ce qui est très très
nécessaire alors on est un peu dans une
situation où il va falloir un moment
donné revenir à l'équilibre mais on
enlever l'équilibre on l'avait mis dans
la mise à jour avant les fêtes puis on
l'enlever il y a pas d'équilibre
budgétaire en vue même si comme vous
dites le déficit par rapport au PIB
quand même possible la petite différence
entre c'est Carlos croit la prévision de
Madame sur le contrôle des dépenses et
quand je regarde le budget et d'ailleurs
le directeur parlementaire du budget a
dit que il y avait pas été poli il a dit
il y a pas suffisamment d'évidence assez
ouverte dans leur hypothèses moi j'ai
dit qu'il y en avait pas d'hypothèse on
les voit pas alors pourquoi ce contrôle
là il va falloir que les cibles de
dépenses qui sont inscrites dans le
budget il va falloir accessible la soit
atteindre
et bon c'est pas gagné c'est pas gagné
d'abord ok on termine sur les problèmes
dans le hockey parce que il y a une
incidence économique extrêmement
importante d'avoir une équipe de acquis
professionnels dans une ville ça peut
avoir des répercussions économiques et
ça vaut cher aussi ramener une équipe
quand on voit les Coyotes de Phoenix les
Coyotes de l'Arizona avec le public la
population qui refuse la construction
d'un nouvel amphithéâtre Carlos est-ce
que le Québec est-ce que Québec doit se
battre et se démener pour ramener cette
équipe là tenter de RAM
je pense que ce qui est arrivé hier hier
soir ou avant-hier un Arizona dans la
ville de tempé c'est une très bonne
chose
à deux égards très bonne chose parce que
d'abord ça ouvre la porte et
éventuellement que ça arrive au Québec
mais deuxièmement peut-être la plus
grande leçon c'est que la population a
dit non pas d'argent public dans une
telle aventure et je pense que moi
sixième conclusion que je tirerais de ça
c'est ça pas vous voulez amener une
équipe professionnelle et pas d'argent
public des milliards de dollars l'argent
public
binder donneded comment dire chinois
exactement parce qu'on a quand même un
amphithéâtre de Québec qu'on a bien payé
quelques 350 millions que je fais comme
ça déjà alors c'est fait ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que québécois va
probablement demander au gouvernement de
de l'aider parce que si vous regardez
déjà là il y a plusieurs milliards de
dollars le gouvernement Jean-Luc il va
dire oui malheureusement parce que
regarder ce qui est arrivé au troisième
alors le gouvernement sent que il doit
compenser une gaffe OK et est-ce que ça
vaut la peine est-ce que ça vaut la
peine d'investir de l'argent public pour
une équipe de hockey professionnelle moi
je voudrais que non personnellement je
pense que c'est non ça ne vaut pas la
peine d'investir l'argent public bonsoir
surtout existe déjà l'Arena est déjà là
maintenant d'investir dans un public
pour l'achat d'une équipe d'une équipe
ça je pense pas moi non plus et on parle
de retombées économique alors quand on
est au plein emploi on va re-simuler
l'économie on a tendance à oublier que
on a un déficit structurel de notre
balance des paiements avec l'extérieur
chaque fois qu'on a un déficit chaque
année on perd notre propriété de notre
économie parce que quelqu'un qui vient
investir chez nous pour acheter ce qu'on
a
pas va se le dire ne retenez pas votre
souffle sur sur l'Arizona
parce que d'autres villes aux États-Unis
il y a un ministre du hockey exactement
suggère de graisser concentré sur
sonodium
alors il va il va prendre ça Monsieur
Girard certains merci beaucoup Carlos
d'avoir été avec nous merci Jean-Luc là
merci beaucoup pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI
[Musique]